welcome to another episode of not too
deep a very special 200th episode I'm
your host grace and hoping the first
here with this guy that Lee just lives
in the floor here living in the forum
immature Davis this is a very fun
episode its cash it's silly it's goofy
it's funny I learned about Mitchell one
has an updated pants shooting story just
leave them with that that's a good hook
I think that's it and we really delve
into like what our friendship means to
us with the pan shooting structure is
actually way more interesting than the
other part so welcome to the 200th
episode of not too deep this episode of
not too deep is brought to you by drop
if you spend with brands like uber
Starbucks Trader Joe's in Sephora then
you're missing out on the free cash
rewards with the drop app for a limited
time you can head to the Apple Store or
Google Play and sign up for the drop app
using the code grace G race EE and
you'll receive a $10 Starbucks gift card
right away make sure to link a debit or
credit card to the app when you sign up
to claim your reward it's happening our
200th episode of not 2d 200 all
everything we talk about has to be in
200s and in like not quite the movie 300
when we hit 300 we're gonna do a full
you're gonna kick me in the [ __ ] yeah
we're gonna do three hundred push-ups
and sit-ups the whole episode it'll
probably take us so many so many farts
that's all I imagine is when I was in
high school I remember the first time I
did push-ups like the Presidential
Fitness thing oh yeah like our gym
teacher had to pull us aside and be like
just so you know there's gonna be toots
there's good parts and if I hear any of
you kids laughing at anyone else just
because they're doing their best but
letting the little gasps you are going
to the principal's office and you know
what that was the safest day in my life
I could fart now even if I'm not doing
anything and if anyone made fun of me
I'm like detention you my body is a
healthy digesting system I'm making a
citizen's arrest
I
the teachers called their disciplinary
like action citizen's arrest this is a
citizen's arrest David you're being a
dick go to the office that was an Ohio
thing that you had to be forewarned of
the gaseous they were so gassy that the
gym teacher was like I've done this a
few times I know to be prepared in my
best interest and yours to just let
everyone know that you're all gonna be
crop-dusted yeah and it was just it was
just like he pulled us in like he was
gonna tell us a secret I I did yeah I am
okay I believe that you did I never had
that warning but in our New Jersey
public school system nor did I ever hear
anyone fart that I can remember really I
think I repressed those memories because
I find them like so embarrassing by like
farts are the funniest thing in the
world to me I'm always the person who
farts I laugh so hard but I also feel
such empathy for the person that did it
that's really sweet someone like that's
good of you but then there's the people
that fart and they don't could give a
[ __ ] or they punch should they do [ __ ]
you know see they do give us yeah
they're yeah they're definitely people
who are like hey truckers help yeah it
was the opposite it's like I'm the kid
who reaches across the table to be like
thanks cuz let me borrow that pencil and
then it's like the whole class is like
ya know the funnies run of Meg's
boyfriend farted himself awake in the
bed next you got once a week is that a
normal thing I was like editing and he
was asleep and he just fully farted and
like sat up shot up like in a panic I
was like what happened I was like no
you're good and I didn't have the balls
to tell him that that's what happened to
like a year later I was like I don't
know if you remember but yeah you fully
like farted so loudly that you jolted
your own body awake that's full REM
sleep
yeah they scare my cat awake with farts
all the time cuz she like curls up right
there does your cat fart no no but she
sneeze is right in my [ __ ] eye
sometimes I'll be good right in her face
being like you're the cutest cat in the
washer and I'm like oh [ __ ] the defense
mechanism
oh she blinded she can't use her words
so she has to get you out of her
personal space sounds purring seems like
she likes it it's just like like it's
like she's like allergic to me for too
long I don't know I love it you did it
last night that's very vivid in my mind
very funny
um and I have 200 cats welcome to the to
Mitchell's coming in hungover I'm here
I'm here I love it I think that's the
most appropriate kind of body sensation
to have for the 200th episode yeah yeah
we hung out this weekend and it was so
[ __ ] fun Mitchell when did you get so
[ __ ] funny he was regaling
Elliot and I was Tories of being in high
school like watching porn with his
friends I mean it's a common thing I
think it's available it's so funny
screaming laughing all night long then I
woke up the next morning my abs hurt so
bad I was like you just did a full like
Netflix comedy special for us and
Elliot's living room right Elliot's
juggling in the corner ways I like how
in his tweet he's like it to impress a
woman I was like you were impressing me
my eye made me feel cool my contact was
between the two of you yeah I know is it
really that was it that was like a true
moment between us yeah at about her when
I got home like I was like wow that was
fully third-wheel it's so cool that
grace hung out with me and Elliot we
thought for a second part of it the
brief idea of trying to come up with
some sort of wonderful format for a
200th episode to celebrate and then out
of laziness and also just the way that
the oh yeah we've cupcakes here that say
200 so that's that's the thing yeah
that's that's fancy and specific as
we're getting we use the for use god
that's so Philly what I just said for
use listening that's such a South Jersey
Philly thing for you guys listening just
imagine that there's three cupcakes on
the table you can't okay if you're gonna
have them imagine we I do a lot better
so imagine there's like okay but you
ever seen the movie hook you know those
politicians about hook okay so think
three of those pies from the fight scene
when those like
they're doing like the whole thing think
three of those crazy colors pastels it's
like a mound of icing I don't know how
you're ever gonna eat it but it says 200
it's spelled out in 200 it's amazing
also why did any of those boys grieve
when Rufio got murdered in front of them
I didn't think yeah I don't know I don't
know oh they all need to be talked to
about how to properly express their
feelings well but to be fair they don't
have a mother so it's it's all like it's
a it's a lot of layered emotional issues
that no one is addressing in that film I
want to get into it yeah we don't they
just they don't address things they just
either skateboard away Orca call yeah
that's what we do Tinkerbell if we don't
know where the origin of toxic
masculinity came from I think it's from
the movie hook okay there's gonna be a
whole thesis written about this out
Tinkerbell professor undying adult love
the only other around her and he just
went cool now because he was a child
mind then look there's a lot of [ __ ] to
unpack it I don't want to hijack this
episode with my thoughts on hook only
because it's like the only movie I
watched like two movies a year so I'm
saying I can't believe you've even seen
it Elliott showed it to me and it was
like his favorite movie that I literally
had to halfway through apologize for
making fun of it so much so I was like I
forget that you're showing me this
genuinely because you love it I love it
I'm just [ __ ] on every angle yeah
he's fantastic
oh and the guy who's like acts knowing
and then slams the door you've got a fry
you've got a curve you've got he's my
favorite I think his name's like toodles
he's like I know maybe I should watch it
again with what they call an open mind
but I don't want to know we thought we'd
just stick to our roots here not change
too much and just answer and rant and
converse about things that you guys have
suggested questions you have I asked you
on Twitter and Instagram and there's a
lot of questions get as many as we can
this episode of them Wow okay well we
only have this studio for an hour so we
can hit an hour of some 200 miles I
don't know how time or math works
okay I'm Dyslexic I asked for rant
topics
topics things need advice on just
general questions and miscellaneous
stuff so okay one is what audience would
you like to hot dog cannon so I think
like what audience what grouping of
people would you like to be in front of
with a hot dog cannon maybe just like a
trump rally I think I'd be like because
that would be think they'd love it
though I don't know but I think it would
just be funny if me just like a non
Trump support just ran out was like I'm
also imagining they're all freezing cold
yeah yes motional yeah yeah I feel like
I would like to do it like a Juggalo
fest they would love I feel like they
would love that's what I mean I would
provide such a joy and also sustenance
because I imagine you know and festivals
like food is sometimes hard to come by
you know what let's just take this I
want to go to one of those like I have a
new answer go ahead okay oh yours I was
gonna say in patch Adams referencing
another robbery yeah he goes to a can
like a like a convention that's for meat
packing okay they would love they would
love a hot dog damn minds
they would lose it okay what about this
a Celine Dion concert okay you got me
you just come after my heart will go on
in the crescendo you just [ __ ] start
shooting now hot dogs all of the hungry
husbands that came with their wives I
gotta be so thankful oh man hungry
hungry husbands you know or we could
just go to a baseball game where they
really do that yeah they really shoot ha
- have you ever eaten a hot dog that was
shot at you from a bit like a no but I
got to shoot out hot dogs at VidCon a
couple years ago yeah when I went with
full screen for not too deep they were
like we have a stage there would you
like to do something on stage and I
jokingly said can I get a hot dog gun
[ __ ] dog cannon and they said yes no
like ha ha ha and then they were like so
you we have you at noon with the hot dog
cannon and I was like excuse you what
and they didn't like show me exactly how
to use it it was nuts and I definitely
pegged a couple kids in the face oh my
god you kids ate it that's awesome
also I think it was really helpful
because those conventions is hard food
and the lines for food are so long I was
just gonna say the hot dog that I ate
out of a cannon was
Aries because it was like fully loaded
but all the toppings are the back of the
momentum could not hold this hotdog
together but I ate it in the crowd I was
just like hotdogs as much I'm vegetarian
like scooping the [ __ ] from the bag
putting it on there being like winners
summer wants to know if we could share
hilarious or sentimental story that we
have offline the we haven't talked about
before we just spent the night
reminiscing them like playlist lives
like early playlist lives yeah the other
day and I forgot so much about what
happens at playlist live but like the
after parties are not the glamorous like
raging things thing I would think they
are no maybe they are now I don't know I
don't go but their day yeah we were just
kind of talking about like the realities
of just like just like where it would be
like a party and then an after-party but
the after-party was just like an empty
room it was just like nothing was
actually happening there the first
playlist live that we all went to and I
think my brother came to my college
roommate came to Michelle no I'm a
Murray came to and we got invited to
like the after prayer by the guy that
like ran playlist at the time and we
were like cool we're cool and then we
got out there and he had absolutely no
booze no anything for anyway I think he
just had a didgeridoo yeah I mean oh
that was a decorative piece of bamboo
that you guys were convinced was a
Didrik that actually sounds right that
sounds right being like that's a
didgeridoo sure at one point someone was
upstairs
talking into it to someone downstairs I
remember that as well we found maybe and
I sniffed out any scrapes of booze that
were in that suite and we poured it
because there's no glasses into the
coffee pot that was there and we just
like all passed this coffee pot around
yeah like gross cesspools of disease I
remember seeing that coffee pot going I
don't I put my lips on that no it was a
poor choice all around I already didn't
like coffee so I was just like whatever
that it was just straight whiskey was it
yeah it was whatever we found there was
like half a little thing of whiskey and
we're like I guess this will do and
there's no cups for everyone so me and
Mike Falzone are excuse me a me and my
friend that I'm not
we just found a volcano and we were just
like this thing yeah we were like well
no we were like I wonder if it's working
I wasn't working so we were there just
being like I don't know if it's working
for like so long that by the time we
found it it was working I was like yeah
it was ten weeks later and you guys are
still in that suite yeah I remember we
were all the first night of that
convention we're sitting by the pool and
we were everyone brought like booze and
food and we're all just like slap
troughs of humans by the pool because we
completely disregarded all of the rules
and regulations that this hotel had in
place and then finally someone came out
and was like you guys can't be here
we're like okay cool and then like six
of us just stood up and walked away but
left like literally mounds of garbage
I need liquor bottles a beer kit yeah I
remember okay so that night is very
vivid to me because that was the first
time I had ever met you yeah and I made
a point it was weird it was like I was I
was good friends with every I mean I am
good friends with everybody who made
playlists them yeah and they were like I
told them I was like when grace gets
here I really want to meet this person
and so Kevin was like hey grace is here
want to meet at the gazebo and I was
like yeah it was as weird like two dudes
came to my room and we're like we're
here to escort you to the gazebo I was
like so oddly formal it was like the
presentation of grace to Mitch it was a
very game of thrones like we were either
gonna get married or duel and and I just
remembered they just it was like they
sat down and all sudden there was like
tons of booze around us and they were
just like converse you to funnies and I
was like okay having like a battle of
conversation used to round the pools
that are closed yeah and I just remember
there being a fenced off area and I was
like this is the coolest weirdest thing
I'm ever gonna do right now yeah it
would seem so chill and I remember like
having a passing thought being like this
is not this is very disrespectful to
this hotel what we're doing right now
I'm still going with it I was like this
is cool
I just remember being like I don't
understand how everything works anymore
I just remember leaving being like this
is so crazy that you can do this kind of
[ __ ] like what is this what it feels
like to be famous I know I'd only been
to one VidCon before that that I like
paid my way to as like a guest and sort
of just like kind of hovered and watched
people from a distance and so that was
the first convention I got invited to
you and I was just like this is like
[ __ ] Hunger Games like everyone there
are no rules here it's it's like it's
like okay vidcon's a little bit more
serious play this is a bit more party so
it's like it's just it already was a
little bit more party but then at first
we didn't even we didn't know what was
happening it was everyone was riding
high I drank probably over my weight in
Froot Loops vodka that whole weekend
which still I loved I still wear those
denim jackets there you go whole weekend
I remember wearing a denim jacket being
like there's like a little demon on my
shoulder like stay on brand though
people expect for you don't you take
that down Jack it off someone's to
surrett about how the carts at the
grocery store never work and I thought
about this I think it is that I think
about that one weird wheel though yeah
it's always why I think I I always
imagined that it's like I just that got
like a piece of hair stuck in it which
then grosses me out to the full maximum
because I'm like who how what this
should never have happened
and also we just need to address the
fact that there needs to be a place to
like you know send the the bad yeah just
a passion centered pasture for old carts
that don't work have you ever done
because I I'm sure I'm saying though
send them to the pasture wink wink glue
out of them just break them down yeah
yeah yeah
the I get so awkward like in social
public settings that I am that person
that pulls a card out that it has a full
wheel that's just screaming the whole
time and I'm like I can't I'm gonna just
double down on this and this is now my
cart that I walk around target with and
I'm gonna pretend I hear nothing and
everything's fine I
don't go back and switch it and I don't
know what it is about like people think
you're a psycho I don't I don't
understand why I think it's easier to
just commit to this terrible cart for
like the next half-hour of shopping
versus taking the next five seconds and
like returning exchanging it look I get
it I don't I I hate I hate getting in
confrontation but if it's with a
inanimate object you just gotta be okay
with it I'm learning to assert myself
like after this conversation you see
grace at a target she just flips a car
and goes you walk away crying really
proud [ __ ] yeah you do though you do you
can always get a basket - yeah it's a
safer that's what I would honestly say
is now I'm a basket boy let's see the
best yeah I try to be a basket girl but
I can't because I obviously want more
than I can fit in my basket and then I
look like that crazy person it's like
two hands like knuckles read on the
basket they're like I made the right
choice I didn't need a cart I didn't
just like gallons of milk flying
everybody I find that as a fun challenge
in the grocery store there you go you
love when someone's like do you need to
help and I'm like no no it's balancing
on my head for a reason this is all
purposeful
get away from me someone to know why is
it so hard to find a new job let's just
[ __ ] the economy Trump do we want to
be real or a joke here
I mean I think that's a little bit real
and jokey at the same time I think it's
hard to find a new job because a Paul
Rudd looks so good at 50 we're never I
don't they're never gonna need me no you
know what I'm saying
that's the problem I'm running to like
we already got Paul Rudd doing it like
damn he's 50 he's too old to be playing
it he's like freaks and geeks or a
rebooting it he's gonna be the main kid
you're casting me is the teacher
oh yeah and kidding about all that I'm
sorry he looks great it does he look so
good how's he do it he's got a yes in
care thing or the Illuminati you think
he's AI oh you think it's a robot
situation maybe AI oh you think he's I
think he hello I am Paul rod if they're
gonna make an AI robot that infiltrates
the human race and brings us all down
slowly
society it's gonna be Paul Rudd he's
charming as [ __ ] no one would suspect it
Wow I'm creating a conspiracy theory
that I really hope that's why I'm
constantly saying much I want people to
just linger with it by themselves see a
lizard person sit with that watch the
video slow them down look at her eyes I
want to see a conspiracy video on Paul
Rudd by the end of tonight please and
thank you note we're gonna take a quick
break what you guys all start collecting
your footage for your conspiracy theory
videos and we'll be right back with this
episode of not too deep is brought to
you by the OkCupid dating app OkCupid is
the only dating app that finds you
someone based on who you are and what
you're into the OkCupid dating app asks
you fun and meaningful questions that
matter to you so you can be seen by the
people who are going to be into you from
questions like would you pay an extra
five dollars for guac to are you close
with your family and did you vote in the
last election you'll see tons of answers
that lead to great conversations and
great dates with people who feel the
same way that you do tell people about
your favorite album your last great trip
or your favorite podcast and let the
love roll in on the OkCupid dating app
whether you're looking for that person
to join you on a long walk on the beach
or a short walk to the pool bar they are
waiting for you on the OkCupid dating
app be yourself and enjoy all the
awesome people like you who want to meet
you on the OkCupid dating app download
the free OkCupid dating app and find
your next great date today this episode
of not too deep is brought to you by
bloom hug me deodorant by bloom that's
BL um e is an all-natural safe and
sustainable deodorant that really works
hug me deodorant is made with probiotics
the probiotics encourage your body to
make more good bacteria and as a result
your body produces less bad bacteria so
be Oh doesn't exist
mainstream antiperspirants contain
aluminum which gets absorbed into our
bloodstream and has been linked to
cancer hug me deodorant is safe
sustainable and leaves you with no smell
and no sweat stains it lasts for at
least 24 hours so you don't have to
reapply throughout the day it's rated
the best deodorant ever by the New York
PO
hug me by bloom keeps you feeling good
feeling fresh and super huggable right
now you'll get 25% off your first stick
and free shipping when you text grace to
four seven four seven four seven this is
a special offer you can't get anywhere
else and you support not too deep when
you support our sponsors so text grace
to four seven four seven four seven and
get 25% off your first stick of hug me
deodorant if you guys have been
listening over the years or know me at
all you know that I cherish deodorant it
is the only way I shower and if you
don't love this hug me deodorant you can
return it for a full refund no questions
asked text grac e two four seven four
seven four seven has there been anything
that someone said to you that was so
off-putting or weird or important and
helpful that like sticks with you I mean
actually I mean there's a ton of stuff
the first thing that pops in my head is
something Kevin said actually to be once
Kevin candy he was just like Kevin is
for people I don't know he was my first
manager he was like the playlist live he
was the guy that had the terrible
after-party at playlist yeah all on you
out Kevin you know maybe and I said it
to your face too
but I remember once I was like freaking
out on the phone he was like whoa whoa
whoa things that you're doing or just
stepping stones in your life to give you
from from level to level
and I would he was like you can't let
this one thing be so big when really
it's just a pebble that you're using to
jump through this like river and I just
remember I was like how many hibbity wet
and then I was like I remember writing
it down and I was just like you might be
the smartest person I've ever met and he
was like that's not sure you're just
freaking out and I was like okay that's
not you're right you're not I'm sorry
you're so dumb you're so humble but but
I just remember that still like whenever
something bad happens I'm like that's
just a stone though I'm just like got a
step to the next one yeah yeah it's
that's a lily pad and like a frog yeah
that's super helpful you're in your own
game of Frogger yeah I can't yeah just
waiting for that car to get me yeah I
keep getting hit and going back to the
sidewalk just responding someone on
Instagram I want all the Instagram
questions I saw that you said as
Instagram for like the first time yeah
well one of the first times that go back
and forth now but I love it because
Instagram it sends you so many also
everyone doubles up I think people don't
realize that they hit sending sends you
know exactly that
it's called spamming crazy but I love so
much is that like I asked for
assumptions and things like that and
sometimes people are really mean and
they're like so direct and blunt you're
kidding but their names are there it's
not anonymous I don't think they realize
that it's not anonymous just being
straight-up mean with your names
attached you guys are dicks from Maci
but someone to know what is something
that everyone looks stupid doing I was
like this is such a great question and
it made me try to think about like what
is something that everyone looks stupid
doing oh I've been falling down I was
gonna say learning how to skate
everybody looks so dumb when they're
first learning how to skate yeah that's
true or learning it right up but it's an
adult learning how to walk again and
that's the funniest thing their arms
become like two sticks and their legs
just like freeze completely like there's
no joints in a bun once their skates on
it that for the first time yeah it's
just like oh she's shaking pogo-sticking
I think it's really difficult to make
pogo-sticking look cool okay
also you know what else is something
that doesn't look cool but like can look
what it's like when someone's bad at
parkour okay yeah I love that parkour
like really good program like whoa but
when someone's like parkour and then
they just do like a normal hop made up
when she was drunk
teeny-tiny parkour parkour and she just
like taps a while okay now if it's that
small I mean purposeful like that it's
very now I'm doing it off this cup yeah
I know everyone looks stupid taking out
their contacts I can I don't even think
about that that's more fun just touching
your eye like that shouldn't be a thing
we're putting on mascara
I think everyone looks really dumb doing
I mean if we're gonna talk about like a
makeup II think I don't even know what
it's called but it's like a clamp that
people use to make their eyelashes like
curl up oh oh you know what I'm talking
about though
oh yeah that eyelash curler
every time I remember the first time I
saw my grandmother okay so I was like a
little kid I'm just talking to her and
she's in the restroom he's doing like
her makeup and I'm just like hey real
quick and she just turned to me holding
that member just literally being like I
just remember being like why the [ __ ]
would yeah any person do that to their
face yeah and then later that night I
obviously snuck in there and did it to
my face and first off never looked more
wide awake and refreshed - it was kind
of sticky and it kind of stuck for a
second it's the most horrifying thing
about okay so panicked twelve-year-old
me I remember just letting out a little
I've heard horror stories of girls
chopping off their whole eyelashes
because they use it too hard or it's
like the padding's not there or
something and that when I heard that
that could happen scared the [ __ ] out of
me that's terrifying it's very very
terrifying Wow
but I'm glad that you did that I did it
they haven't upgraded them or made them
any less like terrifying yep I mean they
look like a device that like medieval 's
would be like I'm gonna use this on you
later
it's torture you're like you don't even
know where it's gonna clamp down you'd
never expect you wouldn't if you showed
anyone that like from another plane you
like where do you think this goes on me
they'd be like I don't know your eyelash
there's the little hairs no never guess
and also you'd never be like that's the
thing that I need okay that's how you
circumcised someone the thing you used
to cut off the ends of cigars which
doesn't look much different so I wants
us to rant about answering professional
emails no it's the worst I'm awful any
time I professional email comes in and
Melissa knows this firsthand because she
constantly has to remail me because I
just go oh this needs a professional
answer I'll show that and answer that
later and then I just completely forget
about it
I I purposely hold emails a little bit
longer so that I can always start them
with I'm sorry I'm two weeks late for
the delay so then my professionalism can
be cut short they know what they're
expecting I was I was really in a bind
here but sorry but you know what you're
saying is right what I'm saying is
you're on cool bye okay cool
let's mating coffee lunch we got it
do you have like a an email signature I
do I have three what I have one for when
I'm [ __ ] around
when I'm [ __ ] someone oh no one I'm
like [ __ ] around of being like a
little [ __ ] to people or it's just like
being funny and it's it's my name and
then it's it just says forever that live
love a live dude and then I have a
professional once like my name with like
all of my links and all that like
creative director and they're kind of
stupid [ __ ] or creative consultants need
one and then and then I have a third one
for if it's my first time emailing
someone that is like just my newest
project happening because I feel like
it's easier to digest oh good for you
did you know
oh yeah yeah extra work yeah who's
getting which email signature yeah I'm
doing the child someone says how often
are you high no judgment I'm right there
with you you should film high um I mean
I think I can't do publicly I get high
to go to bed yeah I was gonna say I and
I get high to like do art or workout or
just like I'm not I'm not like a public
key I don't know yeah I can't I know
like a lot of my friends like that's
their choice versus like drinking I'm
also like an iron lung like I to get me
like stoned bound you know I just it
takes so much that I'm like just keep
your money just save your own expensive
day I can't do it no yeah like even if I
am I I genuinely I don't think anybody
even knows no one even knows I could be
alright
I have no that's the friends that I have
that smoke like regularly and are fully
functional you never know what the [ __ ]
I don't like this for the people
listening he's doing a whole charade
what no I was just listening to you oh
thank you someone to know what's the
most concerning smell not bad but just
questionable fart in an elevator oh that
is a concerning but often awful also I
mean a fart in an elevator
that is like rancid then I'm concerned
that that person's having a terrible
stomach issue that day mm-hmm yeah it's
concerning I also think like a wet rusty
smells always bad or a fire gasps fire
oh you know dirt what's another thing
though that if I smell it I'm like oh
that's not good oh oh and I can curious
I got a good one what when you open the
fridge and it smells like bad food but
there's no food in it that's a bad smell
have you ever had this happen yes I read
your car smell like a fart but you've
never you haven't farted okay and
someone tried to explain that it's the
air-conditioning bringing in air from
the outside into your car because I've
had that happen a couple times where I
go did I just [ __ ] my pants and I have
also lost feeling from the waist down
okay that is not what has ever happened
to me but my car I used I don't know
what the deal was but there was bees
always in my car when I you see I'm into
it and that's not a smell but goddamn if
it didn't suck every time you go in
you're like [ __ ] there's three bees in
here I mean this is a small two-door you
know what I mean there shouldn't be bees
in there I don't even like the windows
being down so like me getting in it's
just like me putting myself in a cage
with three things that could kill me yes
that might be the actual worst next to
drunk driving the worst thing that could
happen
can you imagine pulling out of your
driver being like [ __ ] I just knocked
off my own that's literally how was
though that's I I was it was very funny
I was in a therapy session yesterday and
it got totally usurped because a bee got
in the room and
my therapist is very scared of bees like
10 minutes rest to shoo this be I have
looked bees
you are so important to everything
bumble baby nothing against me that's
true it's around this creature that
scares the [ __ ] but here's the thing
bees you gotta back up your thing we're
not gonna mess with you we already know
that we like need you yeah but just stop
hanging out in one my car I feel like
bees and lately we can't be in in
people's backs I think these are like
those drunk frat boys that are just
looking to fight someone and you're like
guys you're actually good people just
calm down no one wants to fight you here
like knowing what the fight would but
what do I get what my drinking isn't the
thing that everybody does you need chill
Chad's here he's gonna try and punch
that's got it all over his face he's so
fun right now
so okay there's no more no no so many
let's see what what is one thing you
would love to hundred of and one thing
you would hate to have 200 of one thing
I'd hate to have 200 of stds oh wow yeah
that's a lot that's the first thing that
comes to my brain immediately for some
reason for me I was like poison thoughts
of poison sorry Game of Thrones just
came back imagine like a chalice of
poison you don't have to drink bobbing
it's a green just be like like very
annoying they have 200 of them around
yeah how do you dispose a poison without
like ruining your pipes you would love
to have 200 of oh man 200 I mean my
first answer is like French bulldogs but
no the maintenance on 200 friends
Bulldogs walls right it's crazy all the
running noses they can't take in
abilities to breathe it's like we bred
those dogs to just be like noses what
are
they need those what if we took a dogs
now and we scrunch it like an accordion
a main thing that a dog uses to just
like locate anything what if we just
[ __ ] that primary sense and just really
handicap it it oh man I'd saved like
maybe two or more bucks in my pocket oh
that's nice it'd be nice that makes
sense for sure yeah maybe 200 more hairs
on in this beard of mine that I'm trying
to grow okay you know I'm trying to
think logically here suppose my mind
that like men's facial hair grows
differently and like some of people have
patchy what is that do you know why
because we're all different
oh yeah everybody's different it's crazy
cheese I guys stop looking at the world
like a blanket of everyone is exactly
the same okay
I thought equality was a thing but I
guess I'm so sorry but that was like
what the [ __ ] is this episode I'm so
glad you can join me on this show by the
way it makes me feel so good when I get
tweets Oh guess that people respond to
the most I trust me it makes me go this
is the one that's gonna lose everybody
that bit was the best I'm like what oh
yeah cuz someone did ask they said would
you consider revisiting the folks in
your office you work with improv from
the first episode and it took me a
second to remember what that was well we
got so much backlash for that yes
because we said it about a person and
everyone's like you do not refer to
people as it and of course you don't
you'd never say that you would never but
we were like I remember when we got the
email I looked at you and I was just
like but none of these people were real
I don't understand I don't understand
why don't we got an email about that
yeah oh god that's how see I don't
respond that's how we buried unread in
my inbox I was one at six years ago just
one of those jokes that I remember I was
like rats
they got me I didn't even see it and now
I mean you can't and now it's even oh
yeah I saying yeah no I mean and also it
was it's okay I will say there was a
silver lining to that and I feel like it
was a way for a lot of people to educate
me and I learned so much that year about
like
that's Jim they had it how to pronounce
and asking for like what are your
pronounce yeah it was just amazing yeah
what people strive to educate versus
like didn't expect cold twist did you
silver linings no I remember though I
was just like I've got to learn all this
well for people that don't know this
context the game I think was like I just
gave you a name of someone and you had
to describe like as if they were your
coworker what they were like and I was
as I was describing in my mind a person
that was just one giant amoeba yeah so
that we said it because you're like we
could not tell if it was like what it
was is like I think what the joke yes
this was also years ago six years I want
to say seven lifetimes ago it was yeah
we're not years this was almost 75 years
both in our mothers stomachs and they
just put two microphones up to the belly
buttons and we recorded the whole
episode it was really great
Oh Mitch was heartbeat sounds so nice
it's gonna be such a funny guy someday
um I love you were asking to rant about
music festivals and Coachella I didn't
go I don't know but you watch the live
stream right oh the live stream this
year was amazing and that's a you I mean
you made a good point that you're like
my the best seat for these performances
was in my apartment watching this live
stream I just kept thinking about that
sketch from Portlandia where they're
like drone yourself there it's like
don't actually go to festivals just wear
a headset no have a drone they're
walking for you cuz I was like that's
what I feel like I'm doing with this
cameraman yet like I'm sitting on my
couch enjoying like all my nice cool
nice things a bathroom in my bed and all
that stuff and you guys can be sweaty in
something but that I mean the
performances we're so HD that there were
moments where I was like this looks like
a like a 90s movie and also at 60 frames
per second like it was amazing
that's and when you're there for the
when you want to see just the
performances like I get if you want to
be in the environment like experience
the people around you have your lungs
fill with dust and like contract any
sorts of you know the illnesses in a
variety of ways that's your thing but
you know if you really want to see the
performances what a great way to do it
exactly free right and
that's the thing too is I was just like
anyone who was actually there there was
like probably people talking and all
this stuff like they like the childish
gambino set was like he was miked up
they were following him like even when
he went off stage they followed him and
you see him like hug Janelle Monae and
stuff like this you got to see a lot of
intimate moments that you wouldn't get
to see in the crowd and people
definitely were like oh I'm gonna
utilize the camera and keep it as part
of my performance and I loved that this
year like it was just so visual and
there was just things that they were
like I can only say they were doing just
for the camera like no one there knew
that that even happened right right and
yeah it was really great you're getting
these little slices of black I illegally
recorded a lot of it we mean you're not
allowed to record it I mean I don't
think you should but I definitely wanted
to rewatch some of it now yeah I just
but that's the thing I went online to
try and find the performances on there
none of them are there because some
people are like waiting to put them up
and they're do their own thing but I was
like I have to be able to watch this
again
someone to know worst acting you've seen
in a TV show or a movie oh man no this
is an interesting question worst acting
I've seen I don't know I remember I
remember the one movie I ever really
wanted to walk out on was anger
management but I couldn't tell you why I
saw I went to see it when I was in high
school with like my best friend at the
time and I remember both of us there
being like this is bad like this is very
very bad
and I couldn't tell you why we stayed
for the whole thing because we were good
girls and we paid money yeah I mean oh
man it's hard I've never walked out of a
movie just because I feel like if you
pay for a movie you should see the whole
thing right right right but is there
anything that I've just been like no
actually you know what there's been a
few musicals
where I'm just like yep we're gonna stop
here this is good this is a good place
to stop got it you're not I remember
Sweeney Todd I was like we're gonna turn
you off now that was the song that they
cut out of the actual music yeah well I
just remember halfway through the movie
I was like this is the store Hot Topic
is a movie singing to me
directed by Tim Burton starring Johnny
Depp oh sure I didn't see it so I
believe you're humans in it eight humans
like people pies he's saying about it
yes that is right if you shave yeah eat
your pies like there was there was just
one scene where they're like out of
Beach and I was like yeah I'm out this
is the most unbelievable part of this
like if they start singing here I'm
[ __ ] gone I can't handle this [ __ ]
Wow okay we'll give you a second to get
your [ __ ] back together and take one
more break and we'll be right back with
more of your questions on not too deep
our 200th episode support for today's
show comes from Kok Autopia after a long
day it's nice to unwind and enjoy some
me time and what better way to do that
than with a delicious dark chocolate
truffle from coke Autopia
and they've sent me these dark chocolate
truffles guys and they are delicious I
am a sweet - I'm one giant sweet tooth
as a human being and so trust my you
know recommendations when I talk about
sweets you can indulge in delicious
chocolate without the sacrifice on
calories because guess what the dark
chocolate truffle is only 40 calories
which is forty-five percent fewer
calories than lint plus it has less fat
and less sugar - it's the perfect treat
after a meal during a girl's weekend
gathering or paired with a glass of wine
treat yourself visit coke Autopia calm
and enter promo code grace a check out
to get 50% off your first order make
sure you type the code in all caps that
co-ceo t OPI a.com and enter promo code
grace at checkout to get 50% off your
first order indulge without the guilt
this episode is brought to you by its
smile direct let's get something
straight
your teeth smell direct Club straightens
your teeth for 60% less than braces with
invisible aligners sent directly to you
simply go online and book a free 3d scan
at one of their smile shops or order an
at home impression kit then they'll
email a preview of your new smile and
one
to get your aligners one of the small
direct clubs duly licensed doctors will
check in on your progress every 90 days
visit smile direct club comm for real
before and after photos from some of
five hundred and fifty thousand plus
satisfied grin errs and exclusive for
our listeners you can get $100 off your
invisible aligners when you go to smile
direct club.com slash podcast and use
the offer code grace 100 you'll also get
a $25 Amazon gift card with a free 3d
scan at one of their smile shops or a
$25 rebate on an at-home impression kit
that's $100 off at smile direct club
comm / podcast offer code grace 100
smile direct Club calm / podcast offer
code grace 100 oh are you an ASMR person
you know I like to say I'm not because I
think it works that well on me just came
like that just gave me just out that
sounded so perverted ring in front of me
in public in a studio that we don't oh
yes I'm art all over himself I don't
even like finish dinner okay let's speed
round some of these he drowned yeah okay
annoyingly
[Applause]
okay what were your biggest assumptions
about each other I think I assumed that
you were gonna be like a really
depressed sad emo kid what in fact you
were much like everybody Frater and
happier I thought you're gonna be way
taller really yeah I thought you really
liked it like what like rhett tall giant
like seven seven well I don't know I
don't I don't know why but I remember
watching your videos being like that's a
tall person Wow I mean you're maybe the
only person that came and said like you
you're shorter than I thought cool okay
speed round speed five on queer I would
you be fashion hair skin culture food or
decor watch the show well which category
would you be hair skin I like him oh you
would what's been your favorite hair
look hit this right now look you're
growing the roots out yeah no not thick
not the roots but just like keeping it
blonde letting it just be flowy I've you
call it young David Lynch
yeah just very fun yeah I just been
having a lot of weirdness with it yeah
it's still here I'm just like stoked
it's great that becomes more and more
like the most my family was always like
you're not gonna have a lot of hair when
you get older they set you all down I
mean it was just like I just I just knew
a lot of bald people my family so I was
like this isn't gonna last and then when
it keeps going I'm just like [ __ ] let's
burn it now write this try it I think I
would be cool I don't know fashion man
it'd just be you should wear an
oversized sweatshirt and maybe some
skinny jeans for sure I have these
cheetah shoes that you can wear I think
they'll look great on you yeah you've
been wearing those every episode I wear
them constantly until the only shoes
I've ever bought a second pair of what
not bought a fan reached out and they
had found them and so that's the dumbest
[ __ ] answers like your feet look bad
here's a new
I I kind of put it out there that I
can't find these shoes and they're
breaking and I love them so much and I
wish I bought so many pairs in this girl
messaged me and she's like I found these
on eBay can I send them to you and it's
the only time I've ever been like so
cool the least yes I would love them
very much I'll shout out to that person
you know thank you so much take a pair
I'm tens
okay could you imagine if I started
wearing those cheetah shoes I'd be so
mad at you I mean this is all I have
when was the last time you felt truly
proud a few days ago I was just telling
about this I finished my sketchbook
project
yeah that's right yeah it's crazy I 600
pages of of my art that now I'm like
kind of pitching around is like a
youtuber art book that [ __ ] rat yeah
my memoir I finally finished it started
in 2011 and I finished in this year
about a week ago and I'm sorry um but
like I did it yeah I did the last page
and just had like a single tear come
down my face and I was just like holy
[ __ ] that's this is my life nuts cuz
what cuz like I started it when I was
like you know really in the world of
YouTube right now it's I'm so it's so
different my life's so different and you
can see it happen yeah and your
trajectory I know there's a lot of kids
that like get started in YouTube now but
you got started when it wasn't a viable
business operation at all I refer to it
in the book a lot as the Wild West the
digital Wild West we didn't get a little
book I was just riding around on a horse
just kind of working you yeah let's
let's see what we can happen and yeah so
yeah that's the last ones last time you
felt proud I felt really proud after
interviewing Chelsea Handler on this
podcast that that was good thanks yeah
it was I was very very scared and I was
like I felt very proud that I didn't you
know embarrass myself in a variety of
ways that was great I felt like you guys
had a great vibe it was almost kind of
like future talking to young it was like
you guys were very bouncing off of each
other where I was like there could be a
mirror here I don't know it's very
quality is very nervous because she's
very inspiring to me and so it's like I
just want to do a good job for her and
for me yeah and she's just she just
seems I mean obviously she clearly is
but she just seems so real so [ __ ]
yeah
sit she's very very present and very
cool and it's like actually doing like
self-care self work that's really
inspiring to see yeah okay someone says
I've seen three people run into screen
doors and they think I'm next so what is
the right response you just got to keep
your arms out there first you got a feel
about your before you hit it yeah you
got a walk like you're blindfolded yeah
you can't be that excited about a sad or
yes like it has I'm pretty sure if you
don't you haven't lived full a full life
it's like [ __ ] your pants if you
never [ __ ] your pants what are you doing
yeah why even wear pants
if you don't [ __ ] your pants at least
once then you you truly haven't ever
[ __ ]
also what's 30 it's so freeing I ran
into a screen door responsive you're the
one if you run into a screen door I ran
into a screen door I might have the
video still like two years ago
down in Palm Springs over like fourth of
July weekend and I was just like on my
phone making a video to like go inside
and change the music and I ran full head
for headfirst into the glass grab door
and I just laughed so hard at myself I
think one other person saw it but I it's
so so funny also compilations of dogs
running into like sliding glass doors
and screen doors is a really great time
it's all for me it's always those clean
glass doors at moles and [ __ ] okay oh I
think it's like just a square they even
back out I'm like there's clearly no
doors here and then I'll just [ __ ]
ping it just like hard luckily I have
like he's [ __ ] weird big kind of feet
that'll hit at first yeah sometimes his
forehead gets it just like I mean a way
to prevent it it's just walk kicking
your legs first or your hands yeah or
just walk around yelling door door is
there a door door door
I promise people will tell you if you're
doing that what's the response if you
see a stranger like if someone right
next you just full-on face-plants into a
closed door next to you what's your
immediate response less they laugh I act
like nothing happened like oh that's
just a [ __ ] thing that people do you
took that route I'm gonna take the door
I didn't
yeah I think that's kind of my wrist but
unless the person's like then I'd be
like you're okay though you're okay it's
pretty red but you're okay [ __ ] idiot
I mean if it's my friend I'll be I mean
that's a whole different story to
someone I know who then runs into it
yeah
I mean then it's just baby mom yeah then
it's my finger I can point should be of
them going have a new pants [ __ ]
story yeah I do you do I mean I already
tell you the one about the ice cream
right the ice cream and then pooped on
the couch I really cut that down but
that's how it happened I'm gonna leave
it with that I'm gonna add one actually
here's here's my three things okay you
ready five-spice ice cream the couch
[Laughter]
maybe we found out I do know that when
someone five-spice ice cream it was it
was an exclusive ice cream that was a
very spicy and sweet and delicious the
five-spice oh my god and I ate it and
then fell asleep and it just did not sit
well with me I mean I'm glad it was York
out so yeah what did you do to the cat
what'd you do with the counter surprise
fart you know what I'm talking about
oh yeah you don't trust those yeah see
but what was what made it what made it
though is the girlfriend that I was
living with at the time I I said can you
believe I [ __ ] the couch and she goes I
did not know that you should pick out
and that's when I that's when everything
got less funny and I went oh I'm gonna
clean the couch though don't don't worry
like it's just a little bit like it was
oh it was a
surprise fun it was fine I wish there's
a question that's like what's the
scariest thing your significant other
can say to you like oh you noticed for
sure if I'd known I fell asleep on the
couch Eilis yeah that's what the far
woke me up now that's alright look
sometimes in life things happen and
they're gonna be really embarrassing I
doesn't know that it's funny later and
that's one of those things I knew I was
like two weeks from now this is gonna be
one of the funniest things and I even
remember going if grace ever asked me I
got another one now amazing also you
know another piece of advice from that
story it's always scotchguard your couch
for sure and also donate screen before
you go to bed thinking about like just
the fact that it's a dairy product and
being like now I'm gonna go lay down for
seven hours and it's got spices in it to
make it stop you should know better
Mitchell you're an adult man oh my god
yeah it's so [ __ ] funny came right
out of the couch oh I'm sweating this as
well it's not it's not a completely
unique experience to you yeah people act
like shooting your minds is crazy and
I'm like no no no no that's why it's a
lot of adults if you my response to the
person that had this happen I had to go
again I have not been around an adult
that this happens to this frequently I
know this is maybe manifested on me
because I asked people this question all
the time but oh my god you know
someone's gonna be like babe cold
spaghetti just fell out my ass this
whole podcast what have you done to me
oh my god it's not that funny anymore
when it happens to you
nope yeah yeah yeah let me tell you
about it I've been waiting it's been
burst oh God it's been great I'm glad
that you delivered yeah Jesus for sure
200 babe okay someone's know if Mitchell
if you and I went on vacation together
what does that look like I feel like
people might we would be I know for sure
we missed our flight back
Oh getting to our destination would be
the most insane victory I get lost
finding my car at the Grove I would have
booked our flights for like a month
later than when we arrived at the
airport and then we scramble around to
find new flights have to pay like 2,000
extra dollars for new flights cuz I'm
too prideful to just turn around and go
back home and wait a month and then
literally it'll be like oh we have 20
minutes before our gate boards let's go
to the bar and then you just suddenly
hear our names being called over the
speakers over and over again to get to
the [ __ ] game man yeah getting there
would be like the vacation in and of
itself yeah I think we'd have a fun time
if anyone out there wants to sponsor an
adventure Travel Show for Mitchell if we
just go places we'll just rant about
your place just send us there we'll find
all the things that we can rant about we
would love to experience hotels in a
variety of areas in which we can
communicate to an audience our opinions
and thoughts oh my gosh yeah it would be
called the not Amazing Race
that's so good I would totally do that
with you though that'd be so [ __ ] fun
so fun it's just to actual like it's a
to underdog that you're just rooting for
it to get to their destination and then
if they get home that's like a bonus
that's like making it to the Hidden
Temple it's actually just asking the
audience for help for where do you get
food here my wallet my passport
immediately I left everything in the
uber again and my backpacks still on the
plane here
there any way that anyone who has a
cellphone we could use have you ever
left what's like the craziest thing
you've ever left while traveling or lost
uh just a pair of glasses oh really
yeah yeah that was such a nice a bum-out
though I remember I was just like I oh I
will say without a doubt I always leave
my belt at every yeah every place I stay
at I always come home and I'm like [ __ ]
my belt
yeah oh yeah yeah I to the point where
I've now stopped wearing belts like Andy
no even if my pants need to bottom like
[ __ ] I just can't do it I can't I'm
losing money I can't deal with the like
departing this belt any guilt just
growing on me now my grandma got me a
belt for Christmas and to be like good
admit I lost that thing like two weeks
later I mean it was gone maybe just get
pants that fit what just throwing that
out there as a potential no I think you
just no belt just stick to your no belt
rule thank you I would say that sounds
crazy you said like what is make sense
oh this is so funny as I'm looking at
these questions for us on Instagram I
literally had an email come in from the
hotel that I last day that that is
sending me my hard drive that I left my
that's not the whole show season 2 on it
I have full-on left my entire purse in
next to the gate of an airplane I've
gotten on an airplane it was at South by
Southwest when I have many stories of
terrible travel happening for me at
South by Southwest
but Tyler and I were it was it may was a
different festival in Austin Tyler and I
were leaving on the same flight together
we're in the airport just talking to
each other casually I had my purse next
to me and then they like announce our
flight is boarding we get on the plane
we're sitting separately on the plane
and I they come around with a drink cart
and I go to buy a drink and I'm like oh
my [ __ ] god I literally left my purse
full giant bag of everything on the
ground next to the seat that we were
just sitting in like an idiot so that's
I think why we're backpacks way more
often out
yeah they don't day on my back that is
terrifying that just gave me like
anxiety and as I was so hungover from
the festival that I couldn't even react
like appropriately are just like huh
okay
that's there so what is now let's assess
what's the most important things oh all
of your identity and your credit cards
and all your money okay well there's two
grace helbig's out there now
yeah there's totally a bunch scrambling
around I lost my IDs so many times it's
nuts some wants to know describe our
friendship in three words I want you to
go first okay because I I don't I I mean
so many words come to my [ __ ] this is
hard
silly stupid times silly stupid times
see I was gonna say spontaneous uh-huh
weird funny oh yeah impulsive dumb fun
Dave and Buster's and just like right up
already here surely you're here too
that's crazy
okay we've reached the end of our 200th
episode I'm not too deep but we have a
very special thing here we have fortune
cookies to give each other do we pass
these or these okay we pass these two I
honestly don't know what's in yours okay
normally I don't know what's in yours I
didn't even know I was giving you one so
okay a some are here we go oh I'd never
get to do this oh it's fun oh okay
that's kind of fun yeah that's kind of
fun
oh I thought this was empty I did too oh
that's well I feel like a guest on my
own show now this is very fun oh I think
we gave each other the wrong way that
makes more sense
this makes more sense this makes you're
right you're right you're right okay
you'll Miri first and go ahead remember
remember when you were taking a talking
[ __ ] about Mitchell and he said he's a
[ __ ] precious genius who makes anyone
laugh on the cloudiest day oh [ __ ] wrong
okay mine says remember when you were
talking [ __ ] about grace and talked
about how she's one of your longest and
closest friends and you're so relieved
that you get to be there for her 200th
episode I like you this is good
listen Diane thank you guys so you
bastard Mitchell we're as always can
people find you and what you're up to
because you're doing a lot of fun sneaky
projects and they feel like you're one
of those people that spontaneously will
like show some new cool form of new
media that pops up out of nowhere thank
you uh my website is seedy emoji dot-com
where all my links are to seedy emoji
okay and like yes seedy emoji calm and
you could check out everything there and
honestly I've been going live lately on
YouTube oh I'm a streamer on YouTube
that's not even supposed to be a thing
or twitch streaming on you do have a
twist I'm a famous twitch streamer who
only goes live on YouTube oh man Wow
well I'm proud of you for you know
mixing up the media right there's your
new there's your new canvas no one
needed and thank you for being here and
joining us from out of the floor once
again I know on our 200th episode of not
too deep thank you guys for listening to
200 episodes if you have and if you're
just joining us for the first time I
mean I guess you're cool too to
celebrate 200 you should just go back
and listen to all 200 yeah that's the
only way to really celebrate not for me
I never listened to anything
what episodes I listen to them all 200
times see you guys next time on the 200
first episode of not too deep goodbye
2deep 2deep 2deep 2deep not too deep is
a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer and edited by
melissa demons writing by diane kang a
production assistance by Katrina Henning
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]